I have done a lot of videos about tinder
if I don't win this category it is
[ __ ] pathetic are you wasn't gonna go
there but you did next
[Music]
so now we're gonna all set up tinder
profiles okay I've never been on tinder
I'm not really a dating apps type person
everybody's into it you can find someone
to bang tonight that's the point right
okay so Zack is an expert at tinder it's
better to have photos where you're
looking off camera it's really bad just
start with the group photo
hot-hot fun fun funny I know people are
looking for five photos to reel in them
babe no the other guys have ever done
this before so in theory that should
have this hi I'm dr. Jess I am a
sociologist for tinder and I study
online dating and facial attractiveness
hey dr. Jess I guess I'll just hand over
my phone now so real quick you swiping
left or right number one you're wearing
glasses and volume of very nice glasses
it obstructs your eyes but to provide us
with a very strong signal of whether or
not you're trustworthy as an individual
trustworthy let's move on to the next
you're in front of a brick wall it took
its and cubed your cool wall you're not
facing the camera right and you're
wearing your glasses again
why where I need them to see well you
could take them off for the photograph
someone can tell you where to look
okay yeah I'm gonna go ahead and tell
you that there's glasses in every photo
okay that's how I'm dropping I'm
dropping the glasses right now but I'm
here to help okay I know what my best
photo is it's a picture of me and my
Keith shirt holding fried chicken that's
right they're talking about that you're
worried about being lost and people not
knowing if you are and that you've got
cardiovascular disease on your mind that
was good yes exactly
this has nothing about you it's sizzle
I met my wife before online dating was a
thing so I have absolutely zero
experience making profiles I can't see
your face I'm kissing the dog you can
see my bare face I want to see the whole
thing okay we know that by showing your
whole face you're 20 percent more likely
to be swiped right on so I just have to
hold the dog and look into the camera
that actually sounds like a pretty good
photo this is a fun photo it shows you
outdoors and you're also wearing formal
wear which could hop signal that they're
more serious about meeting a romantic
partner so serious that I've already met
one here's a photo of me and this really
cute baby outfit against a dumpster do
you say Fox was at each of T yeah that's
my father
that hoe over there yeah so Eugene what
do you think this photo says about you
I like scanning against dumpsters it'll
be great to know more about you not just
that you like trash
I do like trash here you're in a
photograph with three women free drag
queen I didn't know that these women
were necessarily drag queens they're
just so good at drag yeah I thought I
nailed that one
nope are you in Italy or in Europe Italy
or Europe so that's a good conversation
starter people are going to want to know
more about you talk about your trip to
Europe but I would like to have a little
more backstory about the fact that you
were in Florence at the great Palazzo
Borghese what am I supposed to do dr.
Jess I'm like a sleepy a little bit
sleepy and I'm in front of a nice
background I hate this I'm cute as
[ __ ] that photo I don't know anything
about you I'm smiling kind what you look
like
grew up to something up to kindness not
necessarily none necessarily well we
know that about 10% of tinder users
include dogs and their profile photos
and you like cats I love cats so what
happens if she's a dog owner many people
are dog owners I have two dogs see this
is where this is coming from you showed
me a picture of a dog I'd be like wow
she's a loving animal person bolzen I
have
at the end of the world there's an
animal double standard and I will not
stand for it no more you are abusing
animals the dog looks like it's being
tortured in the back of your great time
oh my gosh I can't where he put me out
he loves being in the bag take him out
of the bag he wanted to be in the bag he
told you this and also you don't own the
suit and so you're stealing I'm not
leaving how do they know that your face
is trained to the point where you look
constipated yeah no I was hulking out
you see I just don't think that this is
a really good look for you yeah well I
don't have any other photos of me with a
giant Lego Incredible Hulk this is my
head as a cake I think this one is
horrifying
you're not smiling either this leox not
smiling you would be afraid too if you
got turned into a cake maybe yeah I
don't know anything about I disagree
there nothing about you you like pie
organs lately what do I know
not that I like pie okay you're not
smiling you're not facing forward and
once again unhealthy food those are not
unhealthy what's the box if it's in a
box okay
that was years recommendation in photo
of you he told me I have to do I'm one
in a speedo my mom's a nutritionist she
says if it's in a box it's unhealthy so
strike does fruit not travel in boxes to
the grocery store they put it in also by
wearing clothing you're going to attract
a far wider audience what a bun how
about this one oh this will get all the
girls just my brain over photo of you as
you away from your wedding day this says
I am available what's the yellow stuff
that looks like bell peppers the yellow
stuff looks like spaghetti
why would I eat spaghetti it develop L
even people who don't necessarily want
children don't want a witness abuse
there's a Christmas tree so you know I'm
somewhere actually I hate Christmas too
so are you trying to tell people that
you like sophisticated music yeah
I can appreciate that we can skip my bio
we don't know BIOS are critical that's
what I heard too I never do you dirt
dirt dirt ariana lyric are you Rihanna
people love reread you I think that you
need so much work it's not even funny
it's a little funny
no I like white wine and traveling the
world let's split a bottle and get to
know each other there are many people
who like white wine and travel abroad
luckily dr. Jes your opinions only
matter so much I already sent it to my
wife and she says I would put the dog
photo first loves dogs
beats TV should I have written more yes
more and something that wasn't so
off-putting I mean I need these photos
better well you need to smile you're not
smiling and hardly any of these photos
oh yeah my mom says that a lot see your
mom does Marlies is your mom no that's
my grandma your grandma my mom's really
pretty
[Music]
Hey ladies let's fall in love each day
that passes with each of us remaining
alone is one less day of bliss hisses yo
future heart you want to talk about you
and what you're about Keith this bio
tells me nothing about you what about
when I said the word bliss me
swiping to the left didn't Edwin I can't
tell you everyone
yeah but I can't you really hated the
other three of us tell you one well
we'll just have to keep it a mystery I
like mystery we all like mister very
mysterious mm-hmm guys I think we all
had very fun cute profiles I would swipe
right there should be an app just for
finding friends that you can make videos
with yeah get naked together yeah yeah
we'll call it the try app Rider the trap
the trap does on our new app the trap
the trap where you can find strangers to
get naked wave and have fun it's it's
rad